Vegeta's sacrifice is a scene adored by
many and disliked by few with it's
heartwarming tender moments its
beautiful artwork and a climax as tragic
as it looks this scene acts as the
moment Vegeta's character arc reached a
point where he was considered an
out-and-out good guy but this iconic
scene has had many different iterations
over the last 25 years and today I will
be focusing and reviewing four of them
going in order of release
I will first take a look at the original
manga chapter from 1994 the original
Japanese broadcast from that same year
followed by the Funimation edit and
dubbed from the early 2000s capping it
all off with Dragon Ball Kai from 2014
to round out our four options but the
interesting thing about this video is
that I will be the one making the final
decision at the end you will once each
of these versions has been reviewed and
broken down I will at the end of this
video offer you the viewer a chance to
vote in a poll for your favor telling of
this epic scene so with that out of the
way let's begin with the very first time
this legendary scene hit the public eye
and to do that we have to go all the way
back to April 19th 1994 coming from
chapter 467 or volume 39 of the manga
titled farewell proud warrior this was
written and drawn entirely by Akira
Toriyama in the mid 90s the cover art
for this chapter sees Vegeta smiling and
wearing the armor he wore during the
Saiyan saga and early Namek saga of
Dragon Ball Z somewhat surprisingly on
the same cover there is also a walker
verse which reads as jus appears as
juvenal's such as my life everything in
this world is but a dream within a dream
this is actually a riff on the famous
death poem of Toyotomi Hideyoshi the
great warlord who helped unify Japan in
the 1500s special thanks to consent you
calm for that info by the way this
particular chapter is exactly 12 pages
long beginning right after trunks and
goten made the save for Vegeta during
Majin boos beatdown of the proud warrior
so how does the chapter present the
events well let's take a look the scene
begins was Vegeta having told trunks to
take care of his mother to which trunks
obviously protests the artwork in this
section is quite angular however despite
this we see her very first glimpse at a
genuinely compassionate looking Vegeta
hugging
son for the first time followed by his
immediate knock out by the prince to
ensure his safety the second he renders
Goten unconscious piccolo arrives on the
scene and majin buu begins walking from
the rubble singing to himself however
before piccolo takes the two kids far
away / VG's request Vegeta has one last
thing to ask of piccolo will I be able
to seek a cross in Otherworld
unfortunately for Vegeta the news is not
good - which he simply replies pity what
follows this brief interaction are some
of the most iconic panels in Dragonball
Vegeta powers up to full piccolo
acknowledges and sacrifice and we are
greeted with that famous original
farewell panel and it's quote goodbye
Bulma trunks and Kakarot iconic last
words that lets all of us know he redid
care a great deal for these people a
flash of light
screaming prince and two people that
truly understand the gravity of it all
truly a beautiful scene next up the
original Japanese broadcast from 1994
specifically airing on August 24th 1994
and yes that's only 18 weeks after the
mangas release of that very chapter
titled for those whom he loves Vegeta
perishes Toei animation broadcast at the
very first animated version everyone in
Japan and many around the world would
see the first thing I noticed with this
version of the scene was what they added
to enrich what was to come for instance
in the manga once Goten unravels Vegeta
from Majin boots constraints Vegeta
immediately gets to his feet where in
the anime this happened this small
addition to the scene works extremely
well in painting a very clear picture of
what trunks thinks of his father for us
the audience watching the scene where
piccolo kills bhavati is quite different
also but I would argue in a less elegant
way within the manga piccolo arrives
behind the evil wizard and after
exchanging some Barb's swiftly slices
him in half and while all that still
happens in this version there is some
added filler such as this scene where
Bobby defends himself using a barrier
and a magical technique which piccolo
overcomes with relative ease it's quite
dramatic and works well for the scene
although if you look care
fully you will notice the producers of
the show trying to get back in line with
the manga was their filler portions are
wrapped up for instance the filler
portion brought this fight to the ground
but in the manga Bobby never leaves the
air so what does Bobby do once his
shields fail on the ground fly randomly
into the air like an actor getting to
his position on stage it's a small
nitpick but it is something I noticed
there's also a hefty amount of dramatic
pauses and cutaways to Goku and Gohan
between what actually happens in the
manga which lasts for a solid
minute-and-a-half plus commercial break
once we return to the scene in question
we get expanded dialogue between Goten
trunks and the Saiyan Prince featuring
Hugh character moments with tragic
ominous undertones thankfully it does a
great job expanding on the source
material before leaving TV Jesus hog
with trunks which lingers alongside the
gorgeous Kikuchi score until piccolo
arrives to collect the children and
receive the Gia's message as the pink
monstrosity hums his way back into the
fray again expanding in sections just
enough to give added weight to the
occasion lines like I'm counting on you
piccolo add to the sense that this is a
truly different Vegeta than what we are
used to hearing what follows this is
pretty much one to one with the manga
from what's explained and even what shot
however when it comes to this scenes big
finale we get a gorgeous piece of unique
animation by Toshi Yuki Kondo
and is one of the most breathtaking
shots in this series to date as Vegeta
screams echo in the background giorgia
nami rounds out the scene with his
famous monologue a warrior vanishes in a
distant astonishing light his name
Vegeta a proud Saiyan Prince there are
some fantastic performances by may you
meet Anika as Crillon and Toshi Furukawa
as piccolo however I think we could all
agree that real horikawa stole the show
with his brilliant and touching
performance complemented by the timeless
shunsuke kikuchi soundtrack for the
series next up Funimation's early
English dub original release November
13th 2001 before I get into this I would
like to point out that this episode was
the last one folks in the West would get
for this dub for almost a full year so
yeah real nice cliffhanger titled final
this would be the first version of this
in the English language for American
audiences something of note there's a
running gag in Dragonball that all the
episode titles pretty much give away or
spoil the twists of any given episode
and despite that being true for the
mangas chapter and the original Japanese
broadcast this particular English
version left it more ambiguous let's say
than the others visually this version of
the scene is almost one-to-one with
Japanese broadcast too however a lot of
the dialogue was altered from the
original and mangas versions for
instance much of Bob Lee's interaction
with piccolo has a few changes like him
threatening just a planet instead of the
universe like in the original
additionally there's this subtle change
yoku devoted his life to protecting the
lives of others because of his
selflessness this change depicts Goku as
again this paragon of heroism and
justice I also thought it worth
mentioning that there are many times
this version chooses to speak over what
would otherwise have been silenced in
the earlier versions using characters
whose mouths are not on the screen at
that given time for instance Vegeta I
think I understand
and one day in civil Trump
on top of that the narrator after the ad
break during that extended look at Gohan
and Goku I talked about earlier fills up
the silence with more of a description
of the events taking place another point
of note is that this versions Vegeta is
significantly less patient and soft
referring to Kakarot still as a clown
fans of this particular dub adore its
score created by one Bruce Faulkner it's
hard to argue that it doesn't create a
very distinct atmosphere one that's
become synonymous with Dragon Ball Z for
fans in the West musically the biggest
difference in tone this scene
demonstrates is during the sacrifice
itself where Kikuchi opted to play this
[Music]
Funimation decided to play this
in the voice actor department stealing
the show during this scene has to be a
young Christopher Sabbat who is playing
both the roles of Prince Vegeta and
piccolo and spoilers it won't be the
last time we see him either next up and
our last option comes Dragon Ball Z Kai
original release
September 7th 2014 back on the bandwagon
with spoiler if ik titles this episode
is called for his beloved ones the end
of the proud warrior what's interesting
about this version is that extended look
at where Goku and Gohan hire in the
previous versions has been moved to the
start of this episode which I would
argue is less jarring this particular
episode actually has more information
crammed into a to not just chapter 467
is included it also contains some of the
end of chapter 466 showing Vegeta's
decimation at the hands of majin buu but
let's get back to where we were with the
last two inches okay fast-forward yeah
right about here this particular version
is available in a host of different
languages through my experience I have
heard both the English and the Japanese
versions with this being the closest the
English version of the show has come to
the manga if that is something that
interests you along with that the long
pauses in the scenes are cut down
considerably less often you will see
characters taking dramatic pauses though
they are still included where necessary
with all that said despite certain
amounts of dead air being removed and
all of it sped up considerably there's
still additional non manga footage used
such as this scene with Bob T and
piccolo something I thought this version
could have done without was the eye
catches for commercial breaks
they are so spoiler heavy throughout the
series and if you are someone who is
trying to avoid spoilers they will be
quite annoying to avoid the highlights
of this iteration specifically for the
English dub has to be Christopher
Santa's excellent performance as a
soft-spoken Vegeta longing to protect
his family and to hug his son needless
to say Ryo horikawa did a fantastic job
for his Japanese performance also capped
off with a tragic speech from the Saiyan
Prince followed by a gut-wrenching
scream
on the music front up until the end of
the cell saga a man by the name of Kenji
Yamamoto scored the series however it
later surfaced that he had plagiarized a
portion of music used and thus when it
was decided to continue the series into
the Buu saga norén hito Sumitomo was
tasked with producing the series
soundtrack action-packed when it needed
to be and beautifully haunting in other
moments this soundtrack provided plenty
of nostalgic beats with just enough
innovation to feel modernized echoing in
the final moments of the scene as the
narrator delivered the final lines of
the episode in a brilliant burst of
light a great warrior meets his end the
Prince of all Saiyans
his name was Vegeta and so as I promise
now that I have broken down the original
manga chapter from 1994 the original
Japanese broadcast from the same year
the early Funimation dubbed from 2001
and the Dragon Ball Kai version from
2014 I would like to present you with
the opportunity to cast your vote which
iteration of the events outline do you
think presented at best I'm genuinely
excited to see what the results of this
poll might be and if this former is
something you guys enjoy let me know
down below by leaving a like or dislike
depending on what you think don't forget
to leave me suggestions down below in
the comment section and I will see you
guys next week thank you so much for
watching
[Music]